who wants to rate this one Ian you guys
uh yeah let me see there's a glare on
the screen so uh I got this Panic is
starting to set in i i
for Democrats it's just it's not just
Nevada and multiple key States Democrats
are not hitting the early vote Plus vbm
numbers they need to counteract an
election day Red Wave John Ross from
election wizard John ralson says for
those wondering I just confirmed that
there is no backlog of mail waiting to
be processed this is not a good scenario
at all for Dems unless USPS not pressing
fast enough no massive Clark mail is in
2020 as I have said this is an apple
other Cycles are oranges so basically
they're hoping there was a big stack of
mail-in ballots they're going to get
jammed up that would be good news for
Dems it ain't there so this might
actually end that night very decisively
you know American one of the things
Americans have always been great at in
my opinion is
being real like this country came from
hard times and when you see someone like
Joe Biden
just flubbing things it's you can't your
spirit cannot deny it it's it's too hard
to pretend like that's okay for a long
time
and that I gives me hope unfortunately
it's like you got to be demoralized to
the place where you give up on the
American dream but it was a nightmare to
begin with you know it was all the
American dream yeah it was all based on
conquest and like OPEC dollar forcing
people to use our dollars well that's
capitalizing off the back of the
destruction of Europe something very
different it's basically that with a
single job you can buy a house get a car
race two kids some chicken yes no it is
that's the American Dreams one person
from nothing can come up and have a life
like
upward Mobility yeah and then what
happens is you get a bunch of these
communist college students who think it
means you can literally not work and
just be rich the American dream was that
you could move to America as a Chinese
immigrant move your family into a studio
apartment and then work eight eighty
hours a week until you finally put your
kids in college and then they then they
get jobs making fifty thousand dollars a
year and don't have to go through what
you did then they can have cell phones
in their own apartment that was the
American dream and then all of a sudden
these these these communists come out
and they're like the American dream is
dead since when was the American dream
that you're born to an upper class
family go to college and then get a
mid-range six-figure job at a tech firm
there's these are people who get jobs at
like Vice and do literally no work all
day don't even show up at the time and
they're like the American dream is dead
there's a video did you see the viral
video of that of that tick tocker on
Twitter the Starbucks yeah yeah she uh
no I had to work eight hours on Saturday
it's like oh oh man it's a it's a a tick
tocker working at Starbucks crying
saying we need a union because they
schedule me to work eight hours on
Saturday and Sunday and it's wrong and
it's not fair the American dream was
that you got to work 16 hours a day and
you got to make enough money to
eventually put your kids in a better
situation that was the American yeah the
immigration story is the story of my
family you know my dad had to sacrifice
a lot risk a lot and fleeing the Soviet
Union yeah I mean working for
essentially slave labor off the books to
try to of course bring me over to to the
United States to give me opportunity and
I know there hey we I have a lot of
opportunities here that I wouldn't have
in Poland I got to take advantage of it
I got to make sure that I'm on my A-game
I got to make sure I gotta work hard
because at the end of the day no one's
going to give you anything and that's a
lesson that a lot of these people need
to learn immediately here's the American
dream that Luke's family were Poland was
a Soviet satellite it wasn't officially
Soviet Union is that it yeah so your
family flees is very this hardship to
come to America and
30 years later or 20 some odd years
later their son having having his father
having sacrificed all this his son
appears in a Times Square billboard ad
several a couple a couple times
that's the American dream well I don't I
don't know you know in all seriousness
do you think your dad ever expected that
the life he would give you would lead to
something so tremendous he he made sure
to make me aware of it when I was
growing up he was like I I almost died
coming here a number of times so you
better make something out of yourself
because if you don't no one else will no
one's going to give you anything here
you got to work hard for it and was he
like why are you chasing around these
people with a camera yeah yeah like he
was like go to college become a doctor
or a lawyer I'm like I hate all these
people and college is a scam and the
whole the whole economy is gonna gonna
fail and then this was right before 2008
I remember that car ride going to school
I was like I'll do it for them because
otherwise I wish I would have never gone
to school but I did it for them I got my
little piece of paper I gave it to them
as soon as I graduated I'm like here you
go this is pointless I wasted a lot of
money I wasted my time I made sure I
took no money from them I worked a
full-time job doing that but this is the
kind of ethic that they teach you you
got to work for it you can't take out
loans you can't borrow money that you
don't have you have to earn it you have
to work for it and that's something that
I see a lot of people missing people
don't have that people don't have that
hunger or that P you know people always
said you know like hey they went to
journalism school and I remember being
there with them they're like yeah we got
to wait four years we're gonna go
through all the lessons and we're gonna
go out there and maybe interview some
politicians I said screw you I'm
stealing a press credential finding out
how you guys do it making it on my own
facing the mayor off next week and I did
and the mayor ended up calling the
school getting me in trouble but that's
a different story uh but I went out
there I was hungry I hated these
politicians who were lying to the people
no journalist was asking them any
legitimate questions and I was like I
have to do it because no one else is
doing it this is my opportunity to
finally fill a void in society that
could help them and that's when I went
on my spree confronting all the
politicians all throughout the United
States there's two American Dreams in
this story your your mom and your dad
fleeing a hardship to give you a better
life and you coming from a family that
had to flee and then making a a better
life for yourself through hard work
that's the American dream
it's waiting right there for you it was
coined by James Trussell Adams in 1931
American dream and his quote life should
be better and richer and Fuller for
everyone with opportunity for each
according to Ability or achievement I
agree with the sentiment the reality is
the Federal Reserve is deciding who gets
the money and if you are born into
poverty you don't have any money so the
dream is like were you born into wealth
did you listen to a word we just said
yeah the upward Mobility like free
speech allows for people to create great
work but unless you play the game the
fascist game what game is Luke getting
federal or is there paying taxes he's
he's shorting the war in Iraq by paying
taxes oh come on it's not personal but
we've all been part of this there's
there's very few people in the world who
have done uh more combating the false
narratives of the war in Iraq than Loop
dude Luke is a golden god
exaggeration there you know my point is
there's a lot of bad things we fight
against them but the reality is in the
United States which is very different
from many other countries on this planet
you can be dirt poor and work hard and
succeed and there's one there's one
factor they found this is scientifically
proven perseverance yeah well you can be
rich and fail and they they you read
these studies they're very fascinating
there was a TED Talk I watched where
they said they found they went to kids
who were born to multi-millionaire
families to billionaire families and
these kids were failing Hunter Biden
look at him how about that and they say
what was causing them to struggle and
fail soft enough of course with Rich
families they're never homeless but the
dude's teeth run out of his face his
laptop is full of all this just just
destruction and Chaos total failure
it was there was one factor no matter
how rich you are no matter how smart you
are no matter how strong you are
perseverance was the one factor in
success and Miles I think you also take
Life by the balls as well you you've
taken advantage of some crazy situations
traveled everywhere what's some of the
craziest places what's the craziest
place you traveled to well apart from
the Tim cast Studio I I I I would
honestly say Main Place in Afghanistan
and those people there work very hard as
well and they've got the same issue they
do and it's America in America because
in America you know you uh you pay for
an expensive degree and you you can't
get a job afterwards basically even if
it's sometimes a good degree
in Afghanistan they actually get free
and very heavily subsidized degrees as
well so these people uh have pharmacy
jobs and they're actually just working
on the streets saying bananas so they
have the same issues I think at the end
of the day
um and that's why I think Afghanistan's
crazy they it's basically um a failed
U.S state because that's what it was for
20 years that's what we did it made it a
puppet state and then now he's seeing it
all crumble down you would need a
hundred years of social engineering to
actually succeed in with this nation
building stuff it's it's ridiculous
ridiculous concept this would be
controversial um if you really want to
Nation build you you cannot have the
population survive because the end of
the day these people are not gonna give
up their religion and their beliefs and
they're very solid and they're
completely different from Western
beliefs you see that in Europe as well
you see all these uh people coming
across illegally and they just don't
integrate they just don't get on and
with Afghanistan it just made them a bit
more radical yeah that's well this is
why you need 100 years you need to erase
previous generations you need to have
the kids who are growing up be brought
up in in a culture that is that is
westernized American and then when they
grow up you have to make you have to
keep separating their their the the the
younger Generations from the older
Generations so that a hundred years can
go by and they can completely have you
can have erased their culture and
traditions it's the only way you'd be
able to do it tough to do because
Afghanistan is Desert so you got like
the greatest things about the United
States that makes it us able to live
like this with huge cities is the
Imports of grain and and corn and stuff
like that Afghanistan is none of that
yeah Afghanistan's technically not even
a country at the end of the day before
vibration of aided it it was just an
enclave of uh several States surrounded
by mountains and dude have a village
here then they wouldn't contact the
other Village on the other side of a
mountain and there's a bunch of tribes
infighting but when when they were
pressured by the Russian Empire and the
British Empire fake basically came
together and said oh one struggle and
fought every single person you know with
the American dream conversation like
there are there is room for upper
Mobility I agree with that but I think
this this what is this guy's name again
that created the the term anyway the guy
that created the term it's 1931 it
sounds like Federal Reserve propaganda
if you work hard you can make it they
just want a bunch of slave workers like
hard work doesn't get you anywhere if
you do it every day at McDonald's you
got to work smart that's true I disagree
with you you will be working for 14 an
hour until it's about learning service
you can learn by working at McDonald's
how customers work what people are
buying when they're buying it you could
meet like-minded individuals you could
make connections there you could learn
how businesses are run you could learn
customer management you could learn so
much about why McDonald's is successful
and you could take what you learned from
being inside of that company learning
their secrets and implementing in your
own business that's working it's not the
CEO of UPS like start as like a loader
of a truck or something I think so yeah
and there's a lot of those stories how
many people can do this though how many
people could be entrepreneurs how many
people could solve our own business or
do their own little Independence
scientifically all that matters is
perseverance as long as as you as you
you remain convicted to your goals you
success
there's there's like okay I'm I I I I
read tons of scientific studies where
they tracked Decades of people unless
you're smart just look it up unless
you're smart you will continue to repeat
the same problem that's keeping you in
the position a little bit of smart but
hungry perseverance and wanting it
really bad that's the key right there
that a lot of people are missing and
they give up because their mental mind
state is is that they're going to be
unsuccessful you got to be smart to
succeed in the United States you got to
be hungry come from no money you have to
make money that's not true yeah how can
you be hungry when you you've got loads
of fast food be given to you when
everything's been handed someone on a
super plastic you're not starving but at
the same time you're staying afloat and
that's keeping people complacent at the
end of the day it's a choice and that
choice is go to McDonald's go get some
beef liver go get some vegetables
they're a lot cheaper and and but but
it's all about where you decide to take
your time and I think the one thing that
is standing in the way is taxes
regulations and rules and license senses
that do prevent a lot of people from
starting their own businesses from being
able to commence Commerce where in the
United States you have police officers
shutting down lemonade stands if we
should be doing one thing is teaching
people positive mindsets and at the same
time getting government out of the way
so people could fix our problems
financially through just pure real
capitalism thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at 8
pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there